there was a man of the pharisees
named nicodemus
a ruler of the jews
the same came to jesus by night and said
unto him rabbi
we know that thou art a teacher come
from god
for no man can do these miracles that
thou doest
except god be with him
jesus answered and said unto him
verily verily i say unto thee
except a man be born again he cannot see
the kingdom of god
nicodemus said unto him
how can a man be born when he's old
can he enter the second time into his
mother's womb and be born
jesus answered
verily verily i say unto thee except a
man be born of water and of the spirit
he cannot enter into the kingdom of god
that which is born of the flesh is flesh
and that which is born of the spirit is
spirit
marvel not that i said unto thee ye must
be born again
the wind bleweth where it listeth and
now here is the sound thereof but can't
not tell whence it cometh or whether it
goeth
so is everyone that is born of the
spirit
you